people of the internet it is official
Hogwarts Legacy has just confirmed a
huge update coming to the game later
this summer now as exciting as this all
is there's some good news some bad news
and then maybe a little bit of
expectation setting that we need to go
through here by now you guys surely
already know that Hogwarts Legacy has
been confirmed as the bestselling Game
of the Year even out selling Call of
Duty and for anyone who says no no no
balers gate or Zelda we don't have
official numbers on either of those so
until we get them and until we can say
hey they did actually outsell Hogwarts
Legacy the crown will remain with Legacy
regardless whether it was first second
or third Legacy was incredibly
successful and sold a ton of copies and
of course so many of those owners have
been left asking okay what's next I love
this game I want more what do you have
for me next Avalanche there was that
quote that had been circulating around
for a while saying they didn't have DLC
planned at this time and while I would
hesitate to call this a DLC since the
details are kind of murky we don't know
everything just just yet what we do know
for sure is that more Hogwarts Legacy
new Hogwarts Legacy content is coming
and it's coming this year as we near the
one-year anniversary of Hogwarts Legacy
we wanted to let our community know that
the Hogwarts Legacy PlayStation
exclusive content will be available on
other platforms later this summer along
with additional updates and features for
the game stay tuned in the coming months
for more details on what's coming to
Hogwarts Legacy this year so the bad
news right there is that a lot of people
actually were expecting February was
when we were going to see The Haunted
Hogs meet Quest launch on Xbox and PC
and possibly even the switch who knows I
wouldn't expect it if I was a switch
owner but it is at least one possibility
that we have to consider now if you
aren't familiar with the haunted Hawks
me Quest don't worry I'm going to show a
little bit of it here but no Major
Spoilers it is widely recognized as
being one of the best missions in the
game one of the longer missions in the
game and clearly a standout piece of the
overall game so if you haven't gotten to
experience that yet I would absolutely
make sure you look forward to that one I
would expect it will be free there's
nothing in here about any kind of
pricing of course it was already
included on the PS5 and PS4 versions of
the game it was simply a matter of
PlayStation paying enough to have some
sort of exclusive content on their
system now while I'm so excited for
everyone to finally be able to
experience that mission I really can't
wait to hear what you guys think about
it for me the most exciting part is the
what comes next the line along with
additional updates and features for the
game now does this mean DLC because I
know that's where everybody's mind is
immediately going to go to and
especially these days with us seeing so
many add-ons and additions to games how
do we even Define DLC at this point
right so I'll tell you guys what I'm
expecting and I always like to be clear
to you guys when I'm putting purely my
speculation hat on so that is the
territory we're entering right now this
is nothing official I haven't heard any
rumors or anything behind the scenes
this is purely just me sharing with you
guys what I would expect based on the
language here updates and features for
the game personally I am not expecting
some sort of major story expansion at
least not for this right here I do think
that's still a possibility at some point
down the road but for this summer update
my biggest expectation is that we're
going to be seeing some quality of life
updates that fans have been asking for
for basically since the game launched
things like a photo mode possibly a new
battle arena also what about bringing
cross wands back how about we make it a
permanent thing where we can just keep
dueling against people in the game or
even Summoner Court bring that back as
well things like that that are already
in the game I think those would abs be
great things that they could add in a
free update and who knows maybe we even
get something like a new vivarium or a
couple of new creatures added but the
biggest one that I am really holding out
hope for is a new game plus mode this
game has resonated strongly with so many
people and as a result of that one of
its biggest criticisms has been that
people actually want to spend more time
with it they run out of content and New
Game Plus ISS I'm not going to say it's
an easy way I'm not a developer I don't
know how much actually goes into making
something like that happen but let's
just say I think it's one of the easier
things for developers to add after the
fact end games now even though they're
being very vague with the language right
now there is precedent for games just
stealth dropping incredible DLCs for
free that no one was expecting of course
they've said we're going to hear more
about this in the coming months so maybe
possibly a trailer showcasing everything
that we're going to get and I don't want
to Hype it up too much man but I do feel
like there's at least going to be one
sort of surprise something big that
we're not really expecting again I'm not
going to say like a full-on new story
DLC with all these extra missions but
one thing we have talked about so many
times with this game and the developers
Avalanche software is just how much they
care about this community how much they
care about this Wizarding World so I
have zero doubt that they have been
watching and listening to all the videos
all the theories all the speculation all
the wants and desires of people
everything that people want to see added
to the game I guarantee you they have
heard all of them are they going to be
able to incorporate every single one of
them no definitely don't expect that but
again I just I I think there's something
in my gut that tells me there's going to
be a little bit of a surprise with this
update maybe something that we wouldn't
even know to expect at this point for
example I don't think anyone saw the God
of War Ragnarok Valhalla DLC coming a
Rog light addition to the game which
they released out of nowhere for free
and almost had it kind of serve as an
epilog for the game I don't want to
spoil it if you haven't played it but it
was just way more than fans were
expecting and I heard really nothing but
good things about the Valhalla DLC I've
also talked many times on this channel
about that ghost of suima DLC the DLC
that added oh man I don't even want to
say it I I I don't even want to say it
to try and get people hyped up for
something that may not happen but in the
context of ghost of tsushima they added
a Cooperative multiplayer mode again
don't use that and say oh Hogwarts
legacy's adding multiplayer they have
been very clear from the beginning about
hey this is a single player game but the
reason I bring it up here is it's
something that nobody would have really
expected for Ghost of sushima and I kind
of think we're GNA get something like
that with Hogwarts Legacy something that
we just can't even possibly know right
now and I'll even give you an example
within the context of Hogwarts Legacy
itself the whole vivarium system and
everything that you could do inside of
those is something that I would have
never speculated about or expected to be
in the final game when they announced
that and revealed that I was just
completely shocked and blown away that
they would go to that length to include
something that they knew would resonate
with fans but maybe something that we
just had no idea or expectation of it
all but what do you guys think what are
you expecting to see in this deal DC let
me know in the comments below now if you
haven't been keeping up with all the
latest news in The Wizarding World a top
level WB executive has actually dropped
a major tease for future Harry Potter
games yeah that's right games plural
check that one out next as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again
soon